welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka definition and with the sixth
episode of lovecraft country now out
it's time to dive into our weekly
breakdown in which we discuss
all of the ins and outs of the episode
there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you haven't had a chance to check
it out yet then i highly recommend that
you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos like this every day and
please drop a thumbs up here now without
the way thank you for clicking this
let's get into lovecraft country okay so
the title
meet me and deku is pretty
straightforward and the sixth episode
predominantly takes place in the korean
city
filling in the blanks about ticks past
in the war tick is a veteran of the
korean war
and this entry doesn't actually pull
from the book with the majority of it
not featuring in the source material at
all
the title of the episode meet me in
daegu is a play on the film
meet me in st louis from 1944 the film
takes place in 1903 and stars judy
garland
it follows the smith family and saint
louis in the build-up to the world's
fair in 1904
and is almost idyllic in its depiction
of life
i think the insertion of daegu is to not
only set the location of the peace
but also to show the general theme of
lovecraft country
the book as a whole is about
representation and taking old classics
that people of color were missing from
due to white writers not including them
this is why we've had a lot of different
genres in the show so far
as it's sort of a victory lap through
the classics
the episode opens with gr watching the
film and she even gets up from a seat
and starts dancing in the aisle and
singing along to it
ding ding ding went the trolley ding
ding ding the notification bell
oh jesus this channel gets worse all the
time however
we realize that the character is just
imagining this and not only is she not
this hyper realized disney character
her real life is much worse 1949 south
korea
is in the midst of a war and it's sad
that this conflict is often overlooked
i don't think i'd heard of the korean
war until i was in my 20s
and even now it's rarely ever mentioned
in england
at least the war ended in 1953 due to
armistice
but it's still a horrifying conflict
that we know has massively affected tick
now jia meets her mother soon he who's
preparing kim chi
jia refers to her as omar throughout the
episode which is korean for mother
the practicing kim jang the process of
making enough food to last the winter
and this speaks to how poor that they
are most of us are quite lucky in that
we'll be able to get food throughout the
winter months
however if their family don't prepare
enough then gr will likely starve
it's here that we also get hints towards
the system of society that exists in
korea
with men being viewed as above women due
to gr's father dying
the family has no respect and they've
not been invited to the gimjang for
years
giar states that when she gets her
medical degree that they will be
respected
but soon he states that the only way it
will return is if she brings home a man
this further shows how having a man
around is viewed as being more important
than an actual achievement
however gr's reluctance to do this also
hints at her past
gr just wants love like how she sees in
the pictures
most notably meet me in st louis but her
reality is far different to this
idealized version of a relationship
and she's had a very rough life we
learned in this episode that gr was
actually sexually abused by her father
and that soon he made a deal with the
shaman in order to kill him
this would be through a beast called the
kumaho which is a creature from korean
myth
this nine-tailed fox specifically preys
on men that have done wrong
and according to the legend it's lived
for thousands of years
lying in the darkness and waiting to be
summoned throughout the entry we learn
that this beast comes with a price
and that gr must repay the shame in
which is known as a mudang
or move for short the latter term moo
refers to a female shaman specifically
and these are said to be able to summon
creatures directly and place them into
the bodies of women who want revenge
jr becomes a vessel for one and she has
to collect 100 souls in order to repay
the debt to the move
cut to her at medical school and the
pressure of finding love is further put
onto her
pretty much all the women in the class
want nothing more than to get married
and they flock around a girl who's
managed to find someone
ask her to tell me more tell me more
like something from greece
and it paints out the picture that
they'll just be happy as long as i can
find love
now one of the girls brags about her man
asking if they could speak ban mal
which i'm guessing is the 40's
equivalent of banging someone on the
first date
turns out that bad mal is actually a
very informal version of korean
that you typically tend to use when
speaking with close friends
john dimal is the opposite of this and
this is typically how you would speak to
strangers or people in formal situations
also yet apologies for butchering all of
the pronunciation
of these words now this guy he moves
bloody fast
and he'd probably get the third base by
the 1950s
they argue back and forth over whether
it's the way to treat a lady or not
and the nurse drops a little hint on how
to make a man fall in love with you very
quickly
gr takes this as fact and she uses the
line on a man
which further cements that because of
the pressure placed on her by her mother
she's more interested in just getting
someone rather than someone she actually
likes
this becomes pivotal in the episode and
we do see why she's doing this
but yeah they're starting to set things
up here now that naichi attends a
meeting
which is a form of speed dating in which
you're meeting
someone see you you learn all the
complex words in korean when you watch
this
channel now gr is berated by the date
and rejected to her face for referencing
american culture however she finds a man
that also loves judy garland
he seems to get along with her but
chooses her friend
youngja instead i don't know if i'm
reading into this but i think this
character
might be gay now there's actually
articles online that reference garland
as elvis for gay people if you can
believe it
and there's a sort of luck in his eyes
that makes me think he rejects giar
because she seems like such a nice
person youngjar even remarks that he's
very dull
and he's likely just chosen her to fit
in gay people during the 40s were of
course looked down upon massively by
society
and it was viewed as a sin so pairing
off a lot of the time was just
easier jio was of course having to do
this in order to please her mother
and yeah i might be reading into that
but let me know in the comments if you
agree
now i love that young jar has no idea
why he picked her
and that she also thinks he's as dull as
ditch water
the phrase in the west is of course dull
as dishwater
so her character saying ditch water
hints at how poverty-stricken that the
people are
giar heads to a barn spots a man
instantly that's giving her the eye and
in retrospect i kind of feel like there
was a slight change in the music
in which it sounded like a magnet and it
could be that this was a bad man whom
the kumio was seeking out
the pair do more than just speak ban mal
and that night the kumio comes crawling
out of gr
and wraps him up in its nine tails
brutally ending his life
during this she absorbs his memories and
as the creature steals his soul
he too becomes part of jia soon he
arrives and says 10 more
and it's here that we discover what's
really going on we jump forth to 1950
and see a cartoon in which some white
men chase a korean native
it's ironic that depending on what
country you go to
the the quote unquote foreigners are
always displayed as the bad guys
and this idea of other races being the
problem was of course reversed in
western culture
this cartoon comes to life with american
troops arriving in the city and tanks
and this interrupts the picture they say
that they're there to fight for the
locals freedom
and hanoi leaflets but the idea of
freedom is juxtaposed by the industrial
warfare symbols of the tanks
gr throws the propaganda in the fire
showing how the natives actually view
the american liberators
and learn throughout the episode that
they're not really the good guys
we also discover that it's gr's birthday
and though typically tay [ __ ] has served
a new year
they're celebrating with this meal
normally it's made with beef
but soon he serves it with anchovies due
to the scarcity of the meat
it's here that we get a tease of what
happened to soon he's husband
as it's revealed that gr absorbed his
memories and recalls anchovies being his
favorite
gr has now graduated to a full-time
nurse and she works in a gruesome
casualties of war hospital
tending the injured soldiers a soldier
lashes out at her
and this further hammers home her
mother's prejudices about the american
troops
this injury would have broken her wrist
but she's okay because of the power that
lives inside her
outside the hospital jia reveals to
youngjae that she's aware that she's a
communist
but that she's not interested in their
differences as she's different too
i think showing this episode through the
eyes of someone viewed as a monster
is a really smart thing to do and we see
that everyone has their reasons for
living the way they do
a lot of the time it's out of
desperation and how people are hated for
their beliefs
which is showcased in the public hanging
of a communist mere minutes after this
conversation
gr spots a soldier eyeing her up and we
cut to the blood-stained walls of gia's
bedroom
so we can kind of fill in the blanks
here we learn that this is her
99th victim and that gr just needs one
more in order to be free of the curse
giar talks to her mother about their
father husband
and we see that gr kind of wrestles with
the idea of killing him
clearly she's gained some empathy for
him after absorbing his memories
but we know that what he did was
reprehensible i'm actually surprised the
show painted him out like this
and we get the idea that gr is sort of
becoming a monster herself
she knows that her father loved her but
her mother says she doesn't understand
what love truly is
because she's not her daughter we get
the feeling that the mudang is inside
jian in some respects
but it could be that she herself was
abused and this is why
soon he is seeing the similarities
between the pair she does however
manifest
and it's creepy as hell watching this
transformation
gr also sings a song about butterflies
to prove that she's still in there
and this could be a nod to last week's
episode in which ruby's transformation
was too littered by imagery of the
creatures
it seems that there are two entities
existing inside her and we'll get into
more of this idea of shades of gray in
just a bit
now not long after gr arrives at the
hospital and the soldier says that they
know there's a communist spy amongst the
ranks
we of course know this is giard's friend
and the troops have narrowed it down to
their shift
the soldiers execute one of their nurses
and it really paints them out in a bad
light
often in fiction especially westernized
depictions of war
the americans are portrayed as the good
guys fighting for truth
justice and the best way of life but in
reality
we know that things weren't black and
white and everything existed in shades
of grey
oh look at other kisses here to save the
day
what oh no but yeah the twist with thick
i can see being a big point of
contention for fans of the show
and again it's cements that no one is
completely good or evil
young jar hands herself over and she's
taken away
we see the theater is also boarded up
and the words communist sympathizer are
written over the doors in red paint
back at the hospital gr sees that tick
has been brought in
and she promises to take his soul giard
genuinely hates him at this point
and hey to be fair i i did as well now
tick can't read his book the count of
monte cristo
because of his glasses being broken and
all the time he stared longingly at it
throughout the season
it now makes a lot more sense he asks
giard to read it to him
and she gives away the ending without
even dropping a spoiler alert
which i'm not i'm not having that like
it turns out that she's just spoiled the
ending of the movie though and not the
book
and this might even be hinting that the
ending of the show will be different to
how it is in the series
but i guess we will see gr actually
starts to see another side to tick
and a soldier with them because of the
environment change
war obviously changes people and it is
pretty much
designed to bring out the worst in you
here she starts to understand in the
same way that she has become a monster
other people have too because of the
trauma they've suffered
jia asks if they've met judy garland and
take laughs it off saying that that
would only happen if he was a butler
and the korean soldier was a chauffeur
he explains how black people are treated
differently in america
and in some ways it paints out the
hypocrisy of black soldiers being asked
to give their lives
and fight shoulder to shoulder with
people even though back home they don't
have the same rights
the korean soldier explains that he was
drafted and pretty much
forced into the war in america he's
looked down upon because of his race
and in korea the fact that he's american
also means that there's a lot of
prejudice surrounding him
he didn't have a choice whereas tick did
and we discovered that
the character just wanted to escape
america we know that montrose used to be
in badly
and i actually have a theory about this
that was inspired by a comment which
i'm sorry i did screenshot it but shout
out to whoever you are now when montrose
was younger
we learned that he was badly beaten by
his father whereas his brother george
was not
i think that his dad knew that he was
gay and was trying to beat this out of
him
he married in order to keep up
appearances and to try and prove to his
father that he wasn't
but as we know his wife had an affair
with george and this could have even
been spurred on by the truth about
montrose
when tick beat him in the last episode
similar to his father
this spurred something on in him that
allowed him to finally be free
as it reminded him of the beatings that
he used to receive as a child
anyway it's likely that tick was trying
to escape his dad
and this is why he fled and also buries
his head in books when he's back home
he still holds on to the memory of him
though which is why he brought the count
of monte cristo with him
both the pair have been changed by their
parents and they bond over this with it
clearly being a conversation that stops
her from doing what she wanted to
that night she returns to the base and
we see the korean soldier in a new light
a better reminder of how the confines of
war can change someone
and make them act a certain way in order
to keep up appearances
though his misogyny is brief it still
shows how the circumstances can change
people
chiara is having to pretend to be a
prostitute in order to get into the base
and this objectification reminds us that
people are not
often seen as people there's a worry
that she's suspected as a communist spy
and she's taken to a tent however energy
finds tick
who set up a judy garland picture for
her through george's connections he's
got her latest film summer stock
and they have a projector and chill
which leads to them going to gr's
bedroom
now summer's stock is about a woman
named jane who allows a group of actors
to use her barn as the theater for their
play
she falls in love with the director of
the piece sort of crossing the
boundaries a bit
which tic and gr themselves are doing in
many respects
tick admits that he's a v card holder
but says that he's fine losing it to gr
because she sees the good in him even
after all the terrible things that he's
done
giar has clearly fallen for him too and
she tells him to get out before her
transformation can begin
her mother arrives angry and jia or
other kumio
has begun to feel love definitely
pronounce that wrong now her mother
spits in her face
because she's in love with the monster
that killed her best friend
jia confronts tick with this the next
day who says that he was
just following orders he's taken lives
in the hopes of saving them
but two wrongs don't really make a right
giar says that just because they've done
monstrous things
it doesn't mean they're monsters they
just have to choose to be better
and i think this is another thing that
the show is hammering home
everyone has probably done or said bad
things in their life
and have been prejudiced towards people
but we can truly change if we accept
accountability
and try to do better take and gr have
sex
and they really bond however her mother
begins to hate her
even more because of what the monster
has made her do
and even with all his bloodshed she will
still have to live with the curse
she tells her that she'll not be able to
control the monster forever and that it
will
eventually come out giar tries to subtly
hint to tick that the kumio is within
her
but before she does tick tells her that
he's earned enough points to go home
and that he wants to take her with him
he wants more make love but the monster
comes out of her
and we see tick's past and future play
out before her
including his death giar tries to plead
with take not to return home as he'll
die in america
but scared by what he saw he leaves and
i don't think the pair ever meet again
soon he returns home to find her
daughter weeping and she takes her back
to the shaman
we hear the voice of a much older judy
garland that's a far cry from the almost
magical person that we've seen on screen
garland lived a very tragic life and
it's clear that we don't always get a
happy ending
she says she's spent years trying to
please people but there'll always be
those that hate you
no matter what and it's very much
symbolic to not only gr
but other races in general i think
there'll always be people that hate no
matter what
and it's a summer reminder that humanity
isn't always sunshine and rainbows
the shaman wants the price paid in full
but all gr wants to know is whether tick
will die or not
the shaman says there will be countless
more deaths the episode ends with us not
knowing what will happen to her next
i actually think that her mother will be
the final soul to complete the ritual
and who knows when tick calls her it
might not exactly be the happiest
reunion possible
now next week we are back in line with
the book if you don't want any spoilers
then
turn turn the hell off now anyway it
looks like we're following hippolyta as
she tries to get to the bottom of
george's death
in the book she finds an observatory and
in this is a portal that center across
the universe
in the show it looks like this portal is
gonna be in the ori
and that's why christina was after it so
much the chapter in the book
wasn't that big on action but it looks
like we're getting an almost
riff on ben here with the entry becoming
an
almost gladiatorial battle i don't know
how it's going to go down
as it looks like it's a big departure
from the source material
but um you know i'm hyped to see what
they do they're doing an absolutely
brilliant job with the show
and yet hats off to them so far anyway
there's a lot to look forward to
and i can't wait to see what happens but
obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts on the episode so make
sure you comment below and let me know
if you missed any of our breakdowns so
far then make sure you check them out
after this
and don't forget we're also giving away
a free copy of the christopher nolan
collection
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of september so make
sure you get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat who's on the
discord server linked in the description
or a heavy spoilers on twitter thanks
for making it until the end of the video
you've been the best and you know i've
been i've been paul and i'll see you
next time
take care peace
you